his Netflix original stand-up special
Bert Kreischer secret time is available
for streaming this very Friday shot at
the Trocadero theater in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and joining us right here
on the show is none other than Bert
Kreischer good to see you Bruce I spent
all my college with you like is that
right I'm being dead serious it's so
creepy running into you because I see
when I go oh so many times you get out
of class go to the tourney house sit in
the lounge and just be you in Stuart
Scott and you just that was our day I
used to say you I mean the business back
in the day before phones so you didn't
have like a phone to scroll through you
were are scrolling we just watch you 20
times just sit there just all day
Rolling Stone magazine discovered me in
1997 yes and he said to me so like I'm
gonna this art this journalists like I'm
gonna follow you around for a day right
so the first day is like all right so
what do we do and I was like oh we just
watched them all day this means - yeah
and I was like that's all we're gonna do
is just watch them all day and he's like
that's all you do and after like the
third episode of a third time oh I'm
like I guess we should go do something
else
it's amazing me the re-airs of those
sports centers that we used to do you
know we would do them at 1:00 in the
morning and then 2:00 in the morning
again and then whatever mistakes were
made or if there was somebody having
trouble throwing strikes out on the west
coast and a game was going on winning
like 14 15 we'd have to sit there and
wait till it finished and we'd go to
sleep be walking off the set 3:30 4:00
in the morning in Connecticut go to
sleep wake up like the next day we
thought well like nobody just watched
what the hell we just saw oh I got the
opportunity to as the way we were
feeling on the other side of the
televisions I got the opportunity to
have more than drinks with Stuart Scott
so I'm in this I'm in New York this has
got to be 2099 mm okay and I'm in New
York I'm starting standing I'm just
starting so this is once - and I were on
the air - yeah yeah okay and and he is
in New York City he's friends with a
friend of mine named Val and they came
and saw me do stand-up and I get off
stage I did good but you're not staged I
see Stuart Scott that's the best is when
you get offstage and see the celebrity
you're like oh I just murdered they're
gonna love me right and he was like he
was like you funny and I was like aw
thanks he was like we should go get a
drink and I was like okay this before
cellphones this is when you had to talk
to someone right and so we sat and had
drinks and then he goes I haven't eaten
do you mind if I eat I was like oh
yeah order a three-course meal and we
talked and I was like and I was like
what's the one thing I need to notice I
just started my career ago how do I make
it in this business he's like this is
where you cringe he goes ignore the
haters and I said oh yeah and I go oh
yeah
and he goes he was I used to get a lot
of hate when I first started I go I know
he goes how do you know but he was great
he was really generous we ended up
I mean I'm ended up having probably five
drinks he ate a meal and it was great he
was a sweet guy I thought the advice he
gave me was take your shirt off doing
standing I met that's why you take your
shirt off doing stand I wish I had a
real reason of why I knew I took my
shirt off I just did it one time and
then if it worked it works and then I
was on the road and you know there are
no rules on the road so you're drinking
smoke a little weed take your shirt off
and then next thing you know you go to
shoot a Showtime special note you'll be
wearing a shirt right you're like oh I
haven't worn a shirt in seven years on
stage I'm not doing it now and then I
did it for my Showtime special my
machine story went viral shirtless yes
and then it got to the point people
would run into me and they're like I
know you wait oh I didn't recognize you
with your shirt on hmm and then when I
did Netflix they're like you're not
wearing a shirt right and I was like
yeah and so on yeah now I'm never
wearing a shirt for stand-up okay and so
that's every time now that's every time
I do stand-up yeah I won't wear a shirt
at all I feel really comfortable
shirtless now you're married right what
does your wife think of that piece of
stand-up material of me shirtless yes
sir well just of you taking your shirt
off and that's part of your gig
obviously she knew what she was getting
into
yeah she's perimenopausal she looks at
me like she looks at I'm like a perfect
body for a for a 48 year-old woman
because they're like Oh life insurance
policy this is gonna be nice so just
what she's thinking
yeah no dude in the steam room looks at
me like hello but man older white women
whole collect two million dollars in
five years write a book get a new
boyfriend put the girls in college
comedian Bert Kreischer here on the Rich
Eisen show okay let's get into it now
we are a safe for work environment here
on the Rich Eisen show can you tell the
reason the store
as to why you were nicknamed the machine
yeah okay when I was 22 I got involved
with Russian mafia by the way I never
heard a story start that way by the way
I know okay so I went school Florida
State and I signed up I wasn't a good
student I signed up for rushing class
think it was Spanish and next thing you
know I'm in a Russian class the teacher
was like just take the class I'll give
you a C we need people to take the class
I take four semesters never learn it
this is Florida State Florida State yeah
this is the Charlie Ward work done years
and so oh yeah skating by the shoes were
free and Russian class too
dude I got past it a lot of classes
because they were like just stop coming
you're driving me crazy
I'll give you a C and so I took rush
from one two three and four and then
they're like we're taking a trip to
Russia if you go you got a minor I was
like I'm in so I went to Russia and
there's one the mob ran everything in
told us at they're like the mob runs
everything we paid him off and they were
my neighbors so the first night I
grabbed a bottle of vodka and a six-pack
of Baltic which is their beer and I
meant to say a sentence but when I came
out of my mouth from the door open and
I'm faced with a face with a gangster
all I said was I'm the Machine in
Russian he started laughing hysterically
broadly a roomful in nine Russian
gangsters he's like he's the Machine I'm
like on the machine and I got drunk
shot-for-shot with them and then we
party we became best friends
cut two whole class takes an overnight
train trip to Moscow we get two new
gangsters right Igor and igor their
names yeah there weren't a lot of names
in Russia and the and and and second we
get on the play on the train that put me
in first class
the conductor walks in like these guys
love me my guys like this is the Machine
give them vodka you have a blast we
drink all the booze in an hour big
Igor's like machine we go to the bar
clerk to get more vodka I'm like I'm in
the mob I'll do whatever I want
roll into the bar cart thick Igor says
to me in rushing to goes machine go
behind the bar and grab bread in Russian
and I understood him for a second I'm
like language finally I'm learning it my
way not doing flashcards in textbooks
but by joining the mafia I'm behind the
bar
he's like grab pod guys like I already
know that one he's like grab the money
I'm like huh he's I grab the money and I
realized were robbed
being the bar cart grab his stuff go
back to our first-class cabin English
teacher not a Russian teacher English
teacher comes in doesn't a Russian to
our first class cabin opens the door
with that like liberal arts confidence
she's like this is over biggy girl looks
at me takes a sip of vodka spits it in
her eyes and goes no one talks to the
machine like that shuts the door in her
face is gonna screw this chick this is
Russia he's like don't worry machine
when it gets dark we have good time I'm
like you reach into his pocket pulls out
a ring of keys goes we're robbing the
whole train so we robbed him we rub the
whole train what we grabbed the whole
train pulled into Moscow 6:00 a.m.
hammered wasted right train stops Sun's
up
door opens same teacher not mad smiles
at me and goes I want to be the one to
tell you they beloit at the police and
sure enough I see two cops on the
platform talking to my whole class
they're in the pajamas they're upset
they got robbed I get it Igor says he
were goes don't worry machine I talked
to police for both of us goes out to the
cop he's taking a statement grabs him by
the arms spins them around and starts
yelling in Russian I don't know what
he's saying but it doesn't look like I
can make pizza do you like now the cops
just staring at me and I hear me I'll
buddy DJ which I don't know what that
means but it doesn't sound like you're
okay I walked to the cop who's standing
in front of the class I just robbed next
to the gangster I robbed them with he
grabs me by the arms spins me away from
my class away from Igor gets right in my
face and goes so I understand you're the
machine tonight you party with us and I
was like wait wait I'm not in trouble he
goes no screw that chick this is my shop
oh my god so are you I have to ask are
you are you out of the Mafia no oh my
god can I tell you what happened this
girl came up to me and goes um you're
the machine I went yeah and she goes oh
my gosh my whole family lives out in
Brighton Beach and they're all Russian
and they all watch that story and I'm
like that's where the Russian mob is I
am terrified I'm gonna get a corporate
gig one time and they're like yeah show
up it's 20 grand just tell the Machine
story it's gonna be all made men with
tattoo
tracksuits no I haven't talked to anyone
in the mob in a while have you ever
played mar-a-lago no take a 60-second
break we come back with the comedian
Bert Kreischer you've got a Don
Mattingly story that's gonna upset me is
that what I'm told this is my favorite
[Laughter]
Bert Kreischer the comedian with a Bert
Kreischer secret time when we come back
in 60 seconds
[Music]
comedian Bert Kreischer aka the machine
here on the Rich Eisen show so you're
from Florida I grew up in Tampa okay so
you grew up and the with the so I'm
trying to figure it out so you're you
you see you're in college in 97 I was
there for the the Charlie Ward worked on
Derrick Rose heyday
funny when I was in college there was
there was a little these two single
tapes by the counter when you check out
with the gas stations and there was a
tape that said Brooks & Dunn and I
thought oh cool Derrick Brooks and
worked on without a hip hop out I grab
it I buy it it's like a dollar they were
a dollar yeah and I put in my tape deck
and it's country now I'm open-minded guy
was like okay all right I love I love
the way they play you still thought it
was Brooks & Dunn at that point and I'm
like they're not that bad they're not
that bad it's amazing like of course you
know like Charlie pride there are black
guys against in country like that and
I'm like yeah I was like wow that's
amazing and I was playing for people
going do check out Derrick Brooks and
work Dunn's album and they're like this
is good
yeah but I was there during the Charlie
Ward Derrick Brooks days worked on I
graduated and sat next to work done and
he was going to Tampa I grew up in Tampa
we were sitting next to each other you
graduated sitting next to Warrick Dunn
yep and I'll tell you why because I was
written up in Rolling Stone magazine as
the number one party animal and I think
they wanted they said Warrick Dunn and
the place went nuts and then they slid
my name and ripe on him and Bert
Kreischer and soapy no one even heard my
name and they were still cheering for
work done
I sold a most like I was like him and
you go to Tampa I got a lot of friends
in Tampa if you want me to hook you up
with some friends in Tampa and he just
looked at me he's like no in the world
you try to corrupt Warrick Dunn
you try to do that sweet Warrick Dunn
yeah and so and then I was in Tampa
during the Bucs when the Bucs were
absolutely horrible right terrible rudl
but my hero growing up my hero was Doug
Williams though I mean that's the man do
how to rabbit I named the rabbit Doug
Williams are you serious I was
obsessed with dog Williams just my dad
would say things you know when your dad
says something just lays on you he's
like look at the touch this man has you
can just hold it feather into the end
zone
and I'd be like one day that'll be like
me but yeah oh so did you try did you
ever try to play football I played
football I hurt my neck and then just
play baseball and play baseball and then
went to Florida State yeah and yeah
that's a serious program no one went to
walk on first practice coach Martin came
up to me and he's like we got a lot of
catchers but we were always gonna use
the bullpen catcher yeah and I was in
the uniform I walked out left field
fence walked right past all the pitchers
I was like I am not catching bullpen
walk back to Sally dorm Chile William
Paul Pisa were getting high I walked
into my rooms you know we're still on we
see this thing called time travel and
when we get high in pitch black and I
got high listening to Pink Floyd and I
was like I think I'm gonna party
professionally I'm done with baseball
and I was like yup and that's the sport
and the rest is now the Machine exists I
would have never met you as an athlete
what a truly inspirational story but
I'll be honest with you yeah you know
you never know when you know you're
gonna turn that corner and make a
decision in your life so all right let's
get to this Mattingly story what what
happened with you and Don Mattingly
that's ok so just understand this as you
tell this story and I know I'm telling
this to a man who just told that story
about being nicknamed the Machine
because that's the way that you got in
tight with the Russian mafia yeah and
are planning on your next tour to finish
in Moscow and tell that story in Moscow
yeah I fully understand I'm telling that
guy that Don Mattingly is my favorite
baseball player of all time ok Don
Mattingly ok is from Tampa ok
he's from he's from Indiana nobody came
in Fred McGriff would take batting
practice well the Yankees spring
training complex in Tampa limit say okay
I'm not Wikipedia so would take BP at
our high school ok ok so they show up
Don Mattingly just a badass
Mercedes and him and Fred McGriff show
up so this is in the 80s we're talking
in the 80s probably yeah you're probably
89 ok 1889 sure
so me and Scott Beaubier get in trouble
we got to run player appreciations Fred
McGriff and Don Mattingly are taking
batting practice on our field a player
appreciation was when you had
run from home plate to each of the
sponsor signs in the in the fence so
they're taking batting practice and
we're like what are the odds that we're
gonna get hit by a ball so we're doing
left field and I'm talking to Scott and
we're jogging and Scott's tell me some
inane story and all of a sudden a
baseball hits him in the back of the
head and he goes flat on the ground
unconscious and I look up and Dom
madding him Fred McGriff are dying
laughing and I'm like and they're like
sorry and I was like oh my god something
like poppy are you okay and he like pops
up he's like what happened I go fly ball
hit you in the back of the head and he's
like oh and they're like bring the ball
back we'll sign it like okay so we keep
running the show never had the Crime Dog
they have to remember the time we're two
high school kids in Tampa Florida where
they're all in like personal target
practice I can tell you where they
parked the car that's how true this
story is right in front of the Casper
Center in the dirt because I remember
Dom Malley getting out looking at his
rims going oh it's covered in dirt now
it's like we're at the driving range
you're trying to hit the guy in the car
you should learn how good he can go
opposite field they were trying to teach
that at the time it's like play opposite
field with it for like a hit see the
ball look how good he can go opposite
field I was like whoa Toby Rose got CTE
now fantastic your upcoming tour dates
you're right you're hanging out here in
the Southern California area over the
next couple weeks then in Kansas City on
September 13th Madison Wisconsin for
somebody who partied in college that is
gonna be that's kind of like ground zero
for you is it not Mecca
that's where you go and then the end the
guys are like no no no this is the kind
of beer you should be drinking I like
that
no and I look hot they're like I'm a
really in shape whoa you work out I'm
like yeah kinda oh my gosh and what was
it like shooting this in Philly I mean
that must have been a fun time for you
in Philly Bert Kreischer secret time on
Netflix you shot it in Philly it was
amazing Philly's my I like that's my
type of person like those East Coast
cities and it was right after the
Superbowl so they were like all anyone
had to do is and and they would lose
their mind and it was great it was it
was I think the best experience I've
ever had and stand-up you know and it's
all fans they all know me and I've been
there for the parade I showed up when
the parade was there no kidding random
random I just was in Philly I don't know
why I was in Philly and I went in a
depressed in Asti which is the big radio
show and I was walking through the
streets and like that's not one of the
first places I ever told the Machine
story on stage and they were just like
you're walking through don't machine at
one point I got stuck I couldn't get
across the streets it was all blocked
off and I was like I gotta catch a
flight and this guy goes machined I got
you
you got a pound of beer with me and I
was like it's like 8:00 in the morning
I'm like done murdered a beer and he
goes it's the subway systems under the
street I feel like I'm in some sort of
Harry Potter movie Philly man they are
they will they will throw your arms
around you man I know and it they get a
bad rap they always get a bad rap but
they were great to us for the draft and
winning the Superbowl I'm sure it was
all good in that hood that day Wow to be
there as well for that parade
unbelievable and then you know what
tampered as well in Philly they closed
out the Vette and they opened up the
link with a win oh yeah they beat they
beat the Eagles in that NFC Championship
game to go on in the Super Bowl
I remember watching when the 10th when
the Bucs would play the Eagles and I was
like my phone my whole family grew up
into n Philly so you'd have to root for
the Eagles in our house Harold
Carmichael oh yeah holes all dude
Wilbert Montgomery back in that day jaws
Oh jaws and that's when I was like
that's the prototype of a quarterback
and now you look at me you're like how
did you ever do that people I think he
quarterbacks with his shirt off maybe
that's where the two you guys get along
yes you get those tearaway Jersey's when
I get on stage I just
do that before you go you have a story
of betting a ten-year-old at a Rams game
is that yeah yeah yeah we got season
tickets for the Rams
we're all season ticket holders first
game of the first time they're here is
RAM Seahawks that's right yes there's a
week two game yeah and my buddy's kid
I'll say his real name give him a
shout-out
Carter grooves and he's ten years old at
the time he comes out in the Seahawks
Jersey I go bro
we just got eight season tickets to the
Rams you're a Rams fan now and he's like
nope and I was like no you are I'm not
going to a game with you and his
Seahawks Jersey he does I'm a Seahawks
fan I'm like alright bet you that the
Rams beat the Seahawks he goes no way
he's ten and I go bet and he goes how
much I go 200 bucks and he's like okay
take it and then his dad who's buddy you
don't have 200 bucks and he goes what do
you want from me I go schools about to
start on Monday this is Sunday I go if
the Rams win I get to cut your hair and
he was like he's like done and I and his
dad's like hold on once I get think this
bet through Carter school starts
tomorrow
the Rams win Bert cuts your hair he goes
done there's no reason to think it
through
Seahawks gonna win I'm in at 200 bucks
we go to the game I get drunk as crap
and the rams beat the Seahawks right
we're driving home in my expedition and
I am howling laughing googling pictures
of how I'm gonna cut his hair I get my
clippers I get a GoPro I get back to
their house and the first thing I do is
I cut his bangs like simple Jack from
Tropic Thunder and I pull away and I
start crying laughing and this
ten-year-old looks at me dead serious
you guys does it look good this wasn't
the badness that goes this is part of
being a man you should have thought this
best it's all about tough love high
school
the machine ten year old said to
teaching a lesson on sports betting Bert
Kreischer on Twitter check out the
Netflix original stand-up special
streaming on Friday Bert Christ your
secret time let's do this again sir
please man it is an honor to honor and
stay away from my ten year old the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience